you heard of the cocktail party effect
no so the cocktail party effect is me
and you sat here like we've been in a
few bars or restaurants at Terry's
barbecue down the road right the
background noise is a blur it's me and
you chatting but if somebody says Voodoo
events which is Chrissy's old events
company or mentions the northeast of
England or whatever it is suddenly that
background noise what is that you
immediately tune into it so right now
your brain is blurring out infinite
inputs that are happening right now and
you're focusing on what appeals to your
reticular activating system and I think
the case for optimism is you're not
going to manifest things into reality
but if you have a more optimistic frame
you're more likely to spot those
opportunities and I say Market optimism
is a one percent Improvement every
single day and then you'll probably get
more people to believe it so I think
that's the problem with optimism it was
oversold